this is episode 158 of congratulations
[Music]
my babies hey did you think I wasn't
gonna do it
this the [ __ ] turtleneck episode man
and I got him I got that I got the
illest turtleneck on right now and it's
I got I actually didn't mean to not
bring towels I was gonna stack towels up
but dude it's so [ __ ] on man I I got
this turtleneck I bought it with my own
money you should be proud of me
I was with my German friend Matthias and
I had lunch with him he's in LA and I
was like I need to get a turtleneck
let's see if they got turtlenecks dude
we popped in a rag and bone and I got a
[ __ ] turtleneck and this is not an ad
dude this is an ad for sexiness I'm
wearing a turtleneck and dude I look
like a [ __ ] bank robber man like a
like a good like one in the bin Britain
in in 1919 55 and that's so ill and I
got and I got a I got a bunch of drinks
here but I'll tell you what before I
even start on doing shots I got shots of
Cobra so I don't drink but I still want
to be a part of it and it's kind of
[ __ ] I don't get to do shots Oh mmm
[Music]
it's on dude imagine me [ __ ] sitting
in a turtleneck in a French cafe just
doing shots of espresso cold Wow
goddamn dude girls will be like
parlez-vous francais and I would be like
I don't know I up the game dude I
[ __ ] up the game how many of you
[ __ ] know the UH somebody did a
podcast with a turtleneck on anyone
anyone if so their front and broke this
is the real deal
anyway it's episode 158 of
congratulations and I got some dates
here that I'm coming March 20th and
March 24th um first birth March 20 Colin
Firth I'm doing West Palm
Beach Florida I'll be there March 20th
of March 21st West Palm Beach Florida
April 3rd April 3rd I'll be in Robinson
Mississippi and in April 10th I'll be in
Rohnert Park California for some reason
then I got Vegas dates the 17th and 18th
April and then I'll be in Brea
California April 30th to May 3rd and
then May 7th to May 10th gonna be there
gonna just buy a house that I guess cuz
I'll be there for so long and then Vegas
again August 28th and 29th so that's
what's up also a lot of guys want to
know about my opener you know I don't
mention him all the time but his name's
Michael anoche and he's got some dates
coming up to that I wanted to promote
because I wanted people to go to his
show because deep down under it all nice
guy
New York February 11th Gotham comedy
club Boston February 12th laughs Boston
and tickets that website or bio and his
profile that's Michael anoche so you can
go check out the guy opens for me you
know he's norming for me for years so if
you've seen me do stand-up you've
probably seen him so go support him in
Boston in New York I think it's Michael
anoche calm or Michael anoche blend no
ChiCom whoops pissed off messed it up
yes no but yes Michael anoche calm and I
[ __ ] always think about how he uses
the name Michael instead of Mike and he
should just use Mike but it's all good
dude it doesn't matter what's the matter
he's not me thank God by the way dude
here's the other thing too he couldn't
pull off a turtleneck but I got it dude
I got a [ __ ] it's the turtleneck
episode hey dude congratulations it's
the turtleneck episode
Wow dude imagine me just plowing you at
4:30 p.m. with that song with this only
a turtleneck on dude and the turtleneck
goes low and I cut out a hole for the
dick and balls to come out on the bottom
of my shirt and I'm just drilling dude
we drill we drove my babies but I do it
slow and controlled I don't [ __ ]
pop-pop I don't do that kind of sex I
sincerely never did that I I do
beautiful I do beautiful I given if were
having sex like in a basement or if
we're having sex in like a [ __ ]
hallway somewhere it's still it's
practically like we're on the veranda
and and we're French and and curtains
are just blood like the outs that
curtains are just blowing in on the
inside and the sunlights peeking through
and we're in a beautiful [ __ ] bed
with one of those like bottom frame
posts that come up even though that's
annoying because I'm very tall I'm a
tall drink of water obviously but it's
got a bib on the bottom it's got a one
of those foot boards and and and and you
know it's hard for me to keep my legs
extended on it because I have to I have
to bend it up like a grasshopper
anyway it's beautiful when we have sex
in the moran friend i've never had sex
I've only made love anyway do it do it
it's autumn puffin man it's [ __ ] so
on and poppin and it's unbelievable it's
sound believable so Harry Caray's things
that so [ __ ] so [ __ ] it's so
unbelievable ah that song is so [ __ ]
Wow it's unbelievable anyway dude come
see me it's all good who cares if you
don't come it doesn't matter I have this
pocket anyway dude I'm drinking this 40
ounce of water ah shut up to my boy Thea
Rossi but also yeah I'm wearing this
turtleneck and bro let me tell you
something it's [ __ ] sweating bullets
but when you put a turtleneck on if it's
20 degrees and you put a turtleneck on
instantly it's 85 degrees outside and if
you put a [ __ ] turtleneck on nowadays
it's 50 degrees in LA it's 110 what is
it June and Arizona uh anyway
yeah dude uh so that's Jesus I haven't
read legitimately we've been talking
I've been talking for six minutes and 20
seconds literally have said absolutely
nothing but that's all good man because
why the [ __ ] would you come here till
what do you want to learn about the
caucus what do you want to learn about
the [ __ ] caucus now dude honestly the
caucus doesn't even know about the
caucus Dems made that up and they [ __ ]
it all up why are you changing it why
are you changing it just get emails dude
do it old-school
you don't need an app for it you don't
need an app for everything you know
there's a [ __ ] app that will tell you
how you sleep and [ __ ] I don't even
believe in that dude I tried to get this
whoop banned and guess what damn [ __ ]
work dude I put the whoop man how they
said it and it didn't work okay and then
I put my friends root band on to make
sure and no matter what I was doing no
matter how hard I was working out my
[ __ ] what do you call it body my rate
my heart rate was only 92 beats per
minute that's crazy
do you know why I'm not the kind of a
Mutombo okay my heart rate blasts when I
work out because you know it's hard well
especially when I do legs oh and I was
doing legs that day I was doing
eccentric [ __ ] workouts and I was
pausing at the bottom for for three
seconds trying to hold it and my shits
91 bro I wrote back and forth to the
boob guys and we were emailing and they
were like well I didn't see that I don't
see that I don't know if that's true and
I'm like all right cool guess what
click slide over the woop bans gone I'm
not doing it anymore so we all lose so
we all lose I don't know about my bull
my bye what's going on my body dude
maybe i'm gemini man or something but
anyway i got this [ __ ] turtleneck and
it's so on
it's so cool man i look so cool
so that's i guess what we was what up
but that's all we should talk about
about the turtleneck thing but we did
that what do you call it we did the the
thing about how you could text me the
number of cities that i did and on
I'm a community thing and I got it here
someone guessed it dude I said guess how
many this is the best - I said guess how
many cities I played on the
follow-the-leader tour and if you text
it to me I might on my number on my on
my number here you can text it to me
it's a eight one eight maybe it's too
late the contest is already over but
it's eight one eight two three nine
seventy eighty seven eight one eight two
three nine seventy eighty seven and I
said if you text it to me
first person to get the number of cities
can you have free tickets to see me
wherever the [ __ ] you are two free
tickets at a meet-and-greet and the guy
it was Greyson converses his name this
is just his name that he plugged into
that I don't know if that's his real
name
I doubt his last name is actually really
converse but he's probably wearing
converse and didn't want to give me his
real last name but anyway he writes 119
cities buddy and he was [ __ ] right I
said 119 cities on the follow-the-leader
tour and that's unbelievable dude and
that's sound believe oh because that's a
lot of cities some guy wrote me 480
cities and I was like hey guy know so I
wrote you win you're you're you're in
the he's in LA I said let me know
anytime you want to come see me and I'll
get your tickets and say what's up and
he writes haha nice man this will rock
for us and I wrote let me know and he
never wrote back and that was January
28th all good a week ago so I'm waiting
to hear [ __ ] from him now I feel like
the [ __ ] fan bro I'll just show up to
wherever you are man with tickets hey
man it's me and my turtleneck did you
want to hang out so he won and he has
[ __ ] free tickets so that's cool
anyway so he won and that's awesome good
congratulations to him grace in a
converse dude and if you don't and meet
and greet his work let's go to frame
and I'll lay out sideways so I'll have
you seen this is the main thing I want
to talk about today the main thing that
is very important that I want to talk
about that I can't [ __ ] believe is
something this is Ivan dude you know me
everything's jokes I make the jokes I'm
silly being silly and dude I'll never
trying to be a dick like dude here's the
other thing too man I was on Twitter
before I even get into this hey login
dude hey log in so I was on Twitter and
I wrote something look I met MGK you
know at the Comedy Store
we're buds online I like the guy think
he's [ __ ] you know the music bangs
he's a rock star and I write you know he
had that thing where he was playing the
guitar on the [ __ ] Travis Barker
tweeted it and just like that Interscope
will never be the same and Machine Gun
Kelly is [ __ ] rocking out on the on
the table for the people for the
executives where he was having is
listening to his music and I was like
all right cool
and I thought and it cuts before he gets
off the table and I wrote I want to see
footage of you getting down off the
table afterwards Machine Gun Kelly which
to me is funny because there's really if
you're on a table first of all if you're
on a table you're the [ __ ] doesn't
matter what you're doing you can be one
of the [ __ ] bartenders at coyote ugly
you could be Machine Gun Kelly you could
be a baby like a legit toddler on the
table just [ __ ] doing like like wait
like you know what I mean trying to eat
food on the table babies always look at
they're busting nuts you know what I
mean they're always just like so I
tweeted that because I thought it would
be funny and I thought he would laugh
and of course he you know he probably
did and then some people right then he
then you know all my [ __ ] you guys do
it I know a lot of you are trying to
impress me you don't really
Nadia's out there you don't really get
how humor works you know you'll be like
literally like yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and you're like well I'm just joking
that's not a joke dude you know so they
right so so people so a lot of people
were like cringe [ __ ] him this and Adam
I'm like Jesus Christ you know so he's
like he wrote back he was like well if
it was up to your fans I would have fell
on a bag of [ __ ] and broke my ankle or
some [ __ ] I was like yeah you're right
bro
my fans are going ruthless you know so I
wrote him and I was like yo man and he
was like nah man easy target it's all
good daliyah fan for life so my whole
thing is like relax okay you don't need
to [ __ ] go on all cylinders you know
it's like make it like like somebody
said to me like people make fun of what
you know when I put up I'll put up these
workout videos sometimes on my story
because it makes me want to work out
more and then I feel if I don't work out
and I don't post this story on Instagram
then you guys will be like he didn't
work out and he slack he's lagging and
so I need to [ __ ] do more workouts
because let's be honest your boys
getting [ __ ] Vidal right like my abs
are starting to look some like some
double black diamonds and I'll tell you
what Sony just called me and they want
to shoot some [ __ ] outdoor movies on
my back okay I mean I swear if you have
a magnifying glass and if you look close
enough you could you could find Jake
Gyllenhaal and [ __ ] the Heath Ledger
because these are the Brokeback
mountains all right and I'm just telling
you real stuff like this could be on NPR
okay I'm just telling you actual facts
and it's a comedy podcast but my back it
has an atmosphere okay I was itching the
other day and I looked and there were
little birds flying all around what am I
gonna do I love animals I let them fly
around and I still got some sleep but my
point is I actually legitimately don't
know my point okay but we're honest here
on this bit and in this podcast we never
lie
okay when I wear this turtleneck and I
walk around town I pass out towels
because I don't want girls to hurt their
tailbone or ankles but I'm telling you
people go hard in the [ __ ] paint
online there I'm saying like they go
real hard in the paint and I'm always
just joking I really am dude when it all
comes down to it I make fun of [ __ ]
jeremy renner I make fun of this and
that dude I love jeremy renner he's at
his acting is [ __ ] really good all
right there's something though that's
real my babies there's something though
that's not a joke and it's how much I
will never eat Sabra hummus again why
because of their [ __ ] commercial now
I always say this here there should be
no bad commercials period there
shouldn't be bad commercials do you know
why there are 30 seconds do you know why
30 seconds of content should be [ __ ]
easy even if you're trying to get a
message across and you're trying to take
people's money
okay Kleenex or whatever the [ __ ] it is
I saw this is all like just the whole
culture or I don't want to use that word
the whole Superbowl commercial
it's just people who say they watch
Super Bowl just for the commercials are
are the most boring people in the whole
[ __ ] universe alright because do you
know what the commercials on the Super
Bowl they [ __ ] suck alright maybe
there's two funny ones every three years
but like they're not that good
alright also if they're that good they
should always all be that good every
commercial ever so really you're just
being a CUDA thinking they're good
because they think they have to be that
good
commercials are so easy dude the most
famous commercials of all time that have
been spanning a spanning time span
timer spanning time ever that I'm
[ __ ] Buffalo 66 we're gonna spend
time one of the greatest movies ever
asked him for a photo once he said I'd
rather not and I was like oh yeah I
forgot you're [ __ ] weirdo it's all
good and you know the Super Bowl
commercials they pumped so many so much
money into it and they're just so bad
alright and I'm not hating but I you
know it's like get it together be better
they're all glassy and [ __ ]
this Sabra hummus commercial just takes
the [ __ ] cake okay first of all the
catchphrases America how do you mus
alright you're trying to make a [ __ ]
thing you're trying to make a
catchphrase now this comes from your boy
King Oh catchphrases I don't try to make
these catchphrases I don't they pop off
when they pop off I let him [ __ ]
speak to me mm okay I put out in the
world whatever I [ __ ] talk about it's
[ __ ] and when somebody says yeah I'm
a baby I say oh that seemed to work
so now y'all are my babies okay when I
tell you life rips and then when it goes
viral on Instagram the clip about me
talking about how life reps I realize
it's an idea
all right and that's how we promote the
life rips culture and even if you got
bit in the face by a dog life still reps
alright and all of a sudden yeah now
nach making bags off it but that's how
you do it you let the people gravitate
towards you you don't shove a saying or
some mus in people's face okay so Sabra
hummus this got all these [ __ ] suits
in a room and decided well we need a
catchphrase how about we shorten hummus
to muss and then we make it like it's a
[ __ ] verb how do you must now instant
BRM my BRM meter is at an all-time high
now for those who didn't know beer I'm
is his blood-red mad okay
it's risin well am i seeing red cuz the
Bloods up to heger alright so they made
a commercial how do you mus and it's got
now I'm a fan of some of these people
and I've met some of these people and
they're nice people but they put
everybody that's like viral or in a meme
or famous for something either 50 years
ago or 20 years ago or for something
that lasted three days eight months ago
in this commercial and it is just so
[ __ ] what it is that I want to [ __ ]
all over the place and leave it there
for 35 minutes and guess what Sabra
that's how I'm us okay how do you mus oh
well what I do [ __ ] my pants and leave
it there for 35 minutes and don't clean
it up what are you doing Chris it smells
a Mawson all right
so dude this is the commercial and this
is I don't even know who some of these
people are somebody's what I like okay
that's that guy that wrestler guy what's
his name Ric Flair cool
Ric Flair great you're back in the
culture because the [ __ ] what's his
what's the [ __ ] the three migos I'm
gonna call them the three amigos from
now on is that why they're the [ __ ] is
that what it's supposed to be amigos
[Laughter]
you're the three amigos man get some
[ __ ] Mexican hats or whatever they
are sombreros the three amigos you are
the three
migos you're the three migas did I
[Laughter]
figure this stuff out so anyway oh my
god you Moss this guy's back like he's
Count Dracula nice look at could he be
more Dracula all good Count Dracula
oh you mas oh I just [ __ ] DDT someone
dude wrestlers you know now there's this
chick who I don't know it who it is but
she's laying like she's Nicki Minaj and
she's got everything's yellow and she's
then two people that are maybe trans I
don't know am I in trouble now but there
mustn't cuz you got to get everybody mas
in dude if they only had white people
Muhsin or god forbid white straight
white males Muhsin then the whole thing
would be like well Wow
Sabri you're canceled because of Mawson
everyone Muhsin is for everyone dude I
guarantee the aisle that's him that
would be that would truly be what
happened they'll be like Mustang is for
everyone this is [ __ ] and I'd be
[ __ ] in my pants leaving it there
and I even though I'd be the straight
white male be like I just ha I'm Muhsin
and I'm straight white male that's
t-paint obviously no of course of course
that's sad
okay of course that's sad okay why cuz
you know t-pain went bankrupt and if you
don't know you still think about it for
a little bit and you think well of
course you did though so I do secretly
know even though I never read that and
that's also the truth because he bought
houses and all these cars okay then now
I like all these guys I like t-pain's
music I like the next guy the guy who
plays Steve Urkel Jaleel White yeah I
like this guy okay
but course he's in this okay you must
I'm a celery okay now Amanda Cerny it's
sarony right yes I know that like her -
I love her business sense she kills it
it's inspiring but course she's in this
then there's a guy that looks like
[ __ ] Tim Robbins that's not Tim
Robbins don't know who this guy is but
he's Muhsin a pretzel pretzels okay
[Applause]
explosion and explosion these [ __ ]
suits in this goddamn [ __ ] thing a
bunch of dudes just what about and what
about okay boomer we got add that dude
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] me man you're
gonna give a phrase that's got eight
days [ __ ] keeping the internet on
fire [ __ ] three months ago and and
now it's in this commercial with this
[ __ ] chick who is this I don't even
know and then she puts a whole carrot in
there with the [ __ ] leaf on it on the
end like him go [ __ ] yourself
what is she a [ __ ] sociopath she's
got the whole carrot in there with the
leaf on the end like she's Bugs Bunny
dude and then she says okay boomer and
then body rolls explosion dude erm meter
is an all-time high man are you [ __ ]
kidding me dude I want to take everybody
from sob sob rahama stood and I want to
just take him out to dinner in a
beautiful and I want the dinner to last
I don't want him to sleep over I don't
want there to be any sex involved I want
to be hanging out I want to wake up and
I want to go to breakfast with them and
I want to be having a great time and
then dude I want to go get mimosas with
them and then I want to [ __ ] have a
little siesta and have some lunch and
then I want to take some must out and I
want to [ __ ] put a spread out with
all of the [ __ ] things the pretzels
the carrots and all the [ __ ] and then
I want to [ __ ] take him back to my
veranda at [ __ ] 4:30 p.m. and bro
and be like that's how I'm awesome MERP
come on dude okay boomer no dude
everyone on the [ __ ] thing under it
okay boomer okay boomer okay boomer oh
dude that's hey you know what do it
it's not funny also it's been around
boomer is a thing that has been around
for a so long and now just cuz we're all
gonna say okay boomer no by the way the
commercial is 15% through now we had to
make it appeal to the two other to
everyone else besides whites so you've
got this girl that just is pouring
[ __ ] stuff hot sauce in it which is s
racist okay she's to get the [ __ ]
brown lady with the art with the with
the hot sauce oh the okay boomer guy is
the boomer esiason oh oh so it's clever
okay oh so it's clever oh and we can get
Boris Eisen and they said well how do
you know we can get boomer esiason oh
because he's not doing anything now oh
man he's superb okay so then by the way
I know you're watching this [ __ ]
people at Sabra because this park is too
big every time I [ __ ] mention
something I get tweets they're gonna
send me a package of sob ramas and I'm
gonna have to [ __ ] roll around in it
there's a dog
I must pizza and subtitles just and then
there's this kid who definitely is on
tick tock I don't know who this [ __ ]
kid and all the yellow is but he's
definitely on tick tock he's gaming oh
and the asian with the crab bro what why
is this so racist and then you got the
Chester Cheetos guy then this magician
guy which is like it takes it's like
he's doing his magic [ __ ] but really it
doesn't count if it's a [ __ ]
commercial cuz you're just using special
he's not doing it they did it with Sabra
- Sabra people the beef turkey which is
s racist spicy
this is Passport
[Music]
America ulam dracula dude jerker you
know whose goddamn idea was that whose
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass idea was it to have
t-pain sing jerky at the end of the song
also how much is that song a [ __ ]
garage man beat they didn't even pay for
it because they spent every but they
spent so they're like we don't have any
budget left for a song and they'd be
like well Garage Band was popular in
1999 my celery
I'm oz pretzels okay boomer that girl's
actually kind of cute how she does that
I can't hate but also know oh god dude I
want to be in that commercial for real
and I want them to cut to me and be like
I don't [ __ ] muss or me just with
pants on and [ __ ] leaking out of the
[ __ ] ankles and with a bunch of Sabra
I miss all around my feet are in it and
I just go like this and I go like this
this this is how I'm us I don't and then
it cuts but boom pimp O'Neal boom boom
boom pineal and Boomer Esiason dip in a
football in it this is how I might just
gets a little more and more crazy and
then me okay boomer this how I must get
the name bro if I see Sabra hummus
around I'm [ __ ] put my balls in it
kaptara looks listen dude if you work
for a small business or have a side gig
you probably need to find software but
you also have other things to do things
you'd probably rather be doing obviously
well you can cut to the chase with
kaptara the website millions of people
use monthly to find software for their
team or business they simplify the
software search into a few steps
it starts with using their free
resources that's free and guides to
pinpoint the problem and identify the
software features you need I'm all-in
with that obviously then you can filter
options to find the right software for
your industry they have over 700
specific categories of software
yeah that's 700 so that's so many that
you can't even think of that many and
you can even compare them side by side
side and save your favourites to a
shortlist it's very user friendly very
easy to use I've seen it
free in-depth software guides and tools
plus over 1 million reviews from real
users come on man that's awesome
there's bakery software which I clicked
on bakery software and it gave me so
many different software's for bakeries
so if you have a bakery or anything
they've got this figured out just go
check it out trust me visit kaptara com
/ Congrats for free today to find the
software tools you need for your
business kaptara com / Congrats kaptara
that Capt erra dot-com / congrats
kaptara software selection simplified
you know that honey is the free online
shopping tool that automatically finds
the best promo codes and applies them to
your cart and you know how great it
feels to save but how does it feel to
say with honey saving with honey feels
like sliding into a seat on the train
just before the dorks clothes hitting
every green light tear on your commute
and in LA that's awesome
finishing your podcast episode right as
you walk into work you know what honey
feels like saving with honey this is
what it feels like honey has found it's
over 18 million members over two billion
dollars in savings
that's incredible did you know honey
supports over
thousand stores online including Macy's
Target Sephora Best Buy and more and
they're adding more every day did you
know that do you use those big ass
companies yes I'm buying lots of baby
stuff and you know honey has saved me a
hundreds of dollars filling up the boys
closet using a honey feels pretty great
think of it as a little daily victory
plus it's free to use and installs in
just a few seconds get honey for free at
join honey calm / Congrats
that's join honey calm / Congrats uh
yeah dude how do you must okay uh yeah
dude that that that commercial is just
so [ __ ] ridiculously produced it's
just so bad let me do your commercial
sabra's sabra dude you don't know you
don't understand - you have so much to
lose that's the thing I'm telling you
right now if you let me do your
commercials and I'm serious if you let
me do your [ __ ] commercials and then
I'll lace and I'm in a turtleneck right
now and I'm sweating bullets and I
haven't taken it off because I'm down
for the cause dude how much - also I
[ __ ] this is the Tom Cruise I do
realize this is him in the [ __ ] in
his [ __ ] whatever it is with barb
well who's a Barbara Walters is that
what he was talking about when you're a
Scientologist a Scientologist you save
people all right save people yeah
Barbara Waters Tom Cruise 1992 video no
no ice at the 1992 one it's the other
one but anyway he's got a turn mic on
and I have a tonic on so on Tom Cruise
and I you know y'all could go [ __ ]
yourself
so did you watch the Super Bowl
dude I was on that kids Instagram I
actually don't even know his name
I'm so [ __ ] out of the loop what's
his name the Superbowl guy the the
the [ __ ] quarterback Patrick mahomes
the guy who won Chiefs Patrick mahomes
that guy's cool he's like [ __ ] if
Eric Andre put the mask on and so
Patrick mahomes he's awesome I love that
guy just he seems like such a nice guy
and good dude and he scored a lot of
touchdowns anyone the Super Bowl for the
Chiefs and the Chiefs having one in
[ __ ] 21 years so that's cool and and
he is 24 and that's [ __ ] insane to me
the thing that's insane to me are is how
young these guys are now that I'm
[ __ ] now I'm the youngest guy alive
everyone knows that I'm the youngest man
alive but I'm [ __ ] 39 also and it's
crazy that these kids are all so young
and they can just [ __ ] win Super
Bowls and also probably be dish it out
of me and that's so crazy
but dude that's so cool the guy just
looks like he's s so living it up you
know that's the thing when a 24 year old
wins the Super Bowl
it's time to s to live it up one [ __ ]
if the other dude won he's a little
older he just kind of chills probably um
anyway he's he's living it up to it
Congrats to the Chiefs like I give a
[ __ ] but that guy seems like a cool dude
his girlfriend is dude his girlfriend
does the thing where it's like we did it
and it's like okay that's my favorite
when the guys and guys and girls do it
alike they're just like dude we're going
to the Super Bowl and a psych-k
know you are khakis all day long every
day I work also you shouldn't just
[ __ ] scream in an Instagram story at
all it's so annoying when people screw
these are the Instagram stories that
just gotta go
people screaming like people go like
dude don't ever go woo really ever
anywhere really the Superbowl okay a
sporting event fine don't
whoo though all right wooing is just so
goddamn annoying and the thing is sit
and think about that you agree right who
the [ __ ] wants to woo bro I got a
turtleneck on now here's the other thing
at the club I don't give a [ __ ] at the
club all right no at the club where
there's like strobes and oh you're in
Vegas and guess what happens at the club
we'll win
so that's a double no all right when
you're just Instagram story oh my my
girl oh my god me and my girl me and
wifey or the bros just on the standing
on the couches ha ha no dude I don't
want to see that whoops I clicked on it
by axe
another one is pictures of food
obviously everyone has [ __ ] eaten
before I've seen all the food
[ __ ] that there's probably people that
are starving and [ __ ] wherever the
[ __ ] people starve looking at your
Instagram story all like damn that's the
thing you want people to view you don't
want people to actually look at your
story the club did you just want me know
that they were you at the club having a
good time
also I don't want to be there so it
didn't work on me and I'm so cool so you
want my [ __ ] opinion um anyway anyway
dude that was that was uh
congratulations to that guy which is
cool my home remember that song ma ma ma
my homeboy ma ma home MA my homeboy
lighter shade of brown and I would
listen to that song and I loved it and
my dad would say I thought that was song
I thought that song was about a guy
named Patrick Mahoney and he would laugh
so hard and I wouldn't think it was that
funny but whatever he it was funny that
he thought it was funny I like that much
that's the thing when somebody thinks
something's [ __ ] so funny I think it's
extra funny it's probably why I laughed
so [ __ ] hard on my own [ __ ] anyway
[ __ ] y'all [ __ ] how do you mas so
the football game the Super Bowl game is
just the the [ __ ] the halftime show
which I loved it [ __ ] I'm a gay man
do you understand me I'm a gay man okay
the halftime show at the Super Bowl made
me a gay man because I loved it because
I'm sitting there watching Shakira and
JLo and I'm not watching them like I
want to [ __ ] lay them out you know
what I'm talking about I'm watching them
like I'm proud of them
I'm watching them like wow I'm Owen
Wilson in this [ __ ] and I'm watching
them and I'm like J Lo's how old 51 or
50 and she's moving around like that and
also I hate when people say that cuz I
never agree with it but when people say
like yeah she's 55 or 60 and hotter than
ever and it's like k but you know really
what you're doing but J Lo's legit
hotter than ever
she's hotter than she was when she was
25 or whatever or 30 she looks so good
and sexy and Shakira to by the way she
somebody and then somebody at the end
told me and guess what Shakira's 43 and
I was like together they're 93 they told
me I knew JLo had been around but then
somebody like went and guess what
Shakira's 43 like the end of the [ __ ]
movie that I always forget the name of
time to kill not time to kill but the
one with Matthew McConaughey time to
kill and at the end he's like now
imagine she's white and I was like oh
and Shakira's 43 and I'm leaning back
what they're 93 together and they're
they're [ __ ] it up dude and Jay
though had a mirrors on dude how JLo is
it when they're like what do you want to
wear and she was like mirrors and they
they said and they were like why and she
said I'm not answering you figured it
out and then really the reason why was
though because she wanted you to see
yourself when she's dancing to see how
much [ __ ] uglier you were compared to
her while she was dancing see what how
much of a fat piece of [ __ ] you are when
she's dancing killing it
with Shakira and she wanted Shakira to
see her mistakes too
in the mirror that's what JLo did it she
was like I'm just she was [ __ ]
killing it with her book with her [ __ ]
and she wanted mirrors because she
wanted Shakira when she looked over to
see JLo killing it and then Shakira rack
focus to herself in the mirror on how
she's not as good that's what J Lo's
thought was and I'm gonna say Shakira
wasn't as good but that's what her
thought was by the way Shakira was the
[ __ ] for one reason and we all know the
reason because she [ __ ] leaned into
the camera and went so Shakira for
president now my favorite thing is how
the internet went nuts it was like oh
yeah we're representing that's what we
do in our culture for [ __ ] when we
show excitement and it's like people
just flipped out this is a great day for
whatever culture does I don't even know
I'm [ __ ] white and her like this is a
great day for us representing imagine if
[ __ ] like Tucker Carlson did it or
like Anderson Cooper or just even
[ __ ] Adam Levine if he would just one
if he was just like she got that moves
like Jagger she got that moves like
Jagger ooh and he's from it would be
[ __ ] canceled City which is hilarious
you know are you appropriate in culture
or not
either way Elliot's
either way either way let's go to France
my babies dude I need a [ __ ] lay it
out zone where I just like in it's like
you know in a tourist it's in a tourist
hustle and bustle and tourists and
tourism and [ __ ] and I just have a door
and it's me kicking it out there and a
[ __ ] turtleneck and I'm and I'm and
I'm like hey if anyone needs to get laid
out come on in just in the turtleneck
and then they come in and nights go hit
it and I go next and it costs $23 and I
don't even use the money ever I just
save it like Jay Leno with his [ __ ]
Tonight Show money because he me only
the only B he never uses Tonight Show
money if it does you guys know that or
if you don't it doesn't matter should
not explained it you should just [ __ ]
been on my level I don't give a [ __ ]
anyway anyway dude about the [ __ ] I
let me do the ads and then I'll talk
more about the JLo [ __ ]
when you need red wine at post mates
when you need red wine at 4:00 p.m.
sushi at 9:00 p.m. a breakfast burrito
at 8 a.m. and ibuprofen at 10 a.m. post
made it post mates all day long if you
want you can you can stay at home and
just keep eating post mates is your
personal food delivery grocery delivery
whatever kind of delivery service all
year round anything you're craving post
mates can deliver they're the largest
on-demand network in the US and offer
delivery from all the restaurants
grocery and convenience stores is the
place around
yeah then post mates can do it it's got
everything you want to need 24 hours a
day 325 365 days a year post mates will
bring you what you need within the hour
that's all of the days of the year no
more trips to the store you don't even
need to know where the store is post
mates you just is the store around
yeah post might Scott you download the
app for iOS or Android for free browsers
local restaurants and businesses and
track your delivery in real time for a
limited time post mates is giving our
listeners that's the babies $100 a free
delivery credit for your first 7 days so
just get it to start your free
deliveries download the app and use code
Congrats
that's code congrats for $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
when you download the post mates app I
did it
anything you need any time you need it
post made it download post mate since
save with code congrats me undies love
is in the air
someone grab the Lysol nah just kidding
even though this is a made-up holiday
it's still really cute it's also the
perfect time to show that special
someone how much you care and say those
three words everyone wants to hear match
my undies me undies has the most
affordable Valentine's Day prints to get
all lovey-dovey this year don't worry if
you don't have a boo that's fine me
undies also makes buddy band so you can
match with your pet which is honestly
more important than matching with a
person I have four dogs now so need all
those buddy bands
I got I got muddy I got buddy bands for
my dogs I put him on love him hold him
with buddy bands and we love him and I'm
showing him Andris I don't give a [ __ ]
put me on these on me and my girl put me
on these on my dogs put me on these on
my [ __ ] Butler we're all wearing me
undies to show how much they love you my
undies has not one but knew three new
Valentine's Day prints this here so go
on and look at them and me undies has a
great offer for my listeners for any
first-time purchasers you get 50% off
free shipping this is a no-brainer
especially because they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee you don't
like it send back to get you 50% off
your first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to my undies
comm / congrats that's my undies comm /
Congrats dude it's like with the
Superbowl thing JLo and then people were
like out this is what I don't like about
Twitter moments men I'm on Twitter and I
waited about this because I because my
tweets are really [ __ ] important you
know I needed everyone to know so I went
to Twitter as I took to Twitter right
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
[ __ ] bag a few tweets out now is my
[ __ ] loading right now no doesn't make
me mad yeah of course but I was loading
now so it's okay then that should be
blazing had one fire tell me that if
we're gonna do it another one Internet
service provider anyway yeah it was
widely lauded
this was a Twitter moment that I tweeted
it was widely lauded what here this
Denisha Kyra and JLo Super Bowl
performance sparks conversation on
double standards now it says while
Shakira and J Lo's half while Shakira
and JLS halftime performance on Sunday
was widely lauded some viewers come
commented on the artists clothing and
dance moves
several people took the opportunity to
acknowledge that the same concerns
weren't raised right dude here's the
deal if several people are doing it then
it's not a [ __ ] Twitter it's not a
who gives a [ __ ] why are you giving four
people a platform this is the this is
the fringe so then you put it on the
Twitter moments and now everyone thinks
it's a thing and then everyone else gets
mad and it's a huge problem
so Twitter got quests chewed une it's so
annoying they ripped these girls these
women ripped the halftime show
four people are like well off for
Mormons or Catholics are like well I
don't want my kids seeing the inside of
J Lo's leg and so now Twitter puts this
on as a Twitter moment and now everyone
else is like you know the left has got
out of control or whatever the [ __ ] when
the left is fine the rights well but
it's like you know it's so annoying man
it's like a problem Twitter it's
annoying when they do that dude Twitter
is so biased man but what are you gonna
do that's where I get all my [ __ ]
news and gifs what am I gonna do dude
that's how I found out the girl who
[ __ ] drank the Pepsi and didn't like
it and then did like it that's how I
found out about her who's a fan of the
podcast apparently shout-out to her I
see your tweets you're in the hummus
Sabra commercial but it's all good we
still love you baby
yeah that's the other thing too like
people gonna tweet the people in the
Sabra commercial Oh Cruz new
organization on you know I'm not dude
it's all good man make those bags for
real I would have been in that [ __ ]
commercial in two seconds how much okay
this hi I'm us just putting [ __ ] can
I put bubble gum in it so yeah dude it's
the fringe you know it's not the fringe
that's [ __ ] it up it's the [ __ ]
it's it's giving four people a platform
anyway I want to talk about the greatest
acting performance of all time and it's
in one scene and I can't believe I've
never talked about this before but it is
I should have looked it up I just pulled
lieutenant Liu really there's no eating
there
oh so li eu1 fire when he does the
[ __ ] Nicolas Cage when he goes sup
sup you know that scene oh my god dude
I'm looking this up Nicolas Cage sup
dude he keep saying sup in this I'm just
gonna play this is what I get an
argument all the time with my girl about
this [ __ ] Nicolas Cage greatest actor
of all time
alright you know why he makes choices he
makes he takes chances they're not all
gonna be good but because he does that
it makes him [ __ ] amazing
alright Nicolas Cage is an amazing actor
that has done some bad movies but if I
but this is the he keeps coming out with
movies and I'm like alright so he's the
greatest to take a chance and do this in
a movie is the most donkey balled choice
you could possibly make
he's got soman his balls are so large
that he just sometimes relaxes by
sitting on
okay they're like one of those [ __ ]
things that you can find in the toy
stores that you bounce on those were
what his balls are because of this so
he's in a car with three black guys now
it's important that he's white and
they're black because you can tell
Nicolas Cage God he's so good look at
his face just look at his goddamn face
in this [ __ ] thing he wants to
impress them and this is just unreal
unreal that he does this do it that's
money where's the fifteen thousand he
just by saying hey hey stop dude you
don't get it man relax
did I not do what I said I was going to
do
yo man relax tell me again to relax
mhm
I'm not looking to beat you man
where's my money hold the gun on him
I'll get your money when tomorrow we're
so good my place
give me a cut of the uncut dope so I'm
gonna pay you in money okay this is
interest it's [ __ ]
what's that little man no miss Silla
yeah fix the coke now put that gun away
before you kill somebody what's the gun
away kill all you and then
this wasn't there's no way this was in
the script to the break it down amazing
dude how he goes to the break of dawn
baby so insecure but also so secure bro
Nicolas Cage I'll suck you off straight
up then it goes into the [ __ ] bar to
the [ __ ] to this white guy and and
this is what he does you don't pay your
debts I don't want to know you I can't
afford it 10 grand bye-bye oh yeah Oh
putting money in his pocket saying sup
where'd you get this what are you my
priest that's a six point spread oh [ __ ]
he's the best actor there a bean dude if
you don't think Nicolas Cage is the
there's a comment Nicolas Cage caged the
[ __ ] out of this roll I love this man
when he says to the break of dawn baby
daddy's [ __ ] full throttle huh Nicolas
Cage is just so good I want to meet him
so bad that's the only guy I'd probably
geeked-out harder than when I met Keanu
Reeves I don't know that's up there the
two of them are the best different
different Nicolas Cage I genuinely
thinks one of grace actor all-time
counters I think is one of the greatest
movie stars but yeah man Wow
just [ __ ] sup sup hey
I'm jealous he did that now I can't do
it I gotta get more of these [ __ ]
movies so I could take [ __ ] donkey
ball chances man I need to take these
donkey ball chances man just got to get
coffee
um what else
let's look do we have any Twitter
questions or anything like that
sup sup sup bro what is this no this is
oh this is funny what's up with the
Caucasus man I don't give a [ __ ] that
man that man there's something else I
want to talk about can't remember and
it's all good doesn't matter either way
it doesn't matter I don't have it
Instagram most [ __ ] up Instagram I got
to start doing that again most Instagram
most [ __ ] up Instagram post of the
week I do like that here we go Twitter
questions Christa Smith Chris D'Elia
what is your haircare routine so um I
wash it like every 3-4 days depends on
how [ __ ] sweaty I get at the gym
I [ __ ] wash it wouldn't the arctan
dioxin or whatever the [ __ ] because you
never know because maybe who knows if
you'd be losing your [ __ ] hair and so
I keep it to keep it nice and thick my
baby and then every time I wash it with
an accent and put the conditioner in I
pop on now and I dry my hair and bro
that [ __ ] looks phenomenal
my [ __ ] [ __ ] puffs the [ __ ] out
sometimes so hard I look like a goddamn
mushroom and I need to and I need to
honestly take a step back but when I put
a turtleneck on it's cool because my
hair flattens out a little bit and then
bro if I wash my hair and then the next
day put a turtleneck on forget it forget
it
they go Brad Pitt whoo that's what they
do they go Ryan Rhett I can't remember
enols or something that's what they do
when I do that they go [ __ ] why do I
always forget this guy's name got from
Blade Runner not Harrison Ford Donnell
won Ryan Gosling
I [ __ ] always forget his name's weird
mental block anyway also that's what I
do and then I put a little bit of stuff
in it because you know you got a
put it in otherwise it's so frizzy I
don't wanna literally put my [ __ ]
finger in an electrical socket
what I don't know I can't remember I
used to use that Philip B stuff that was
cream of the crop and they discontinued
it dude that's what happens with the
hair [ __ ] man I'll use it for like six
years then they discontinued it I got my
dad hooked up on it and then it
discontinued it and so now I feel like a
bad son um so whose body were you
disposing of in logic and M&Ms homicide
video look by Logan Ritter I you know I
don't know they never [ __ ] said
anything was it somebody I think people
thought it was certain people but I did
nobody ever told me maybe it was
supposed to be somebody an item you know
about it and then what else I got to
start freestyling more coach picking a
rap I have the hottest freestyles dude
[Music]
so so I do ha is [ __ ] free stars man and
I challenge anyone honest and I give a
[ __ ] and I don't rhyme I try not to run
because rhyming
[Music]
that's the thing these rappers don't rap
about real stuff they'll just write
without [ __ ] rims and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] and money and like I like to bring
real actual content you know I mean I
like to I'm like a conscious rapper okay
so go [ __ ] yourself man I kind of I got
to start freestyling more men in my
thirties all right I guess we're done
you know is there anything else that you
wanted to me to do okay I'm done
thank you guys wow I can't believe I
made it the whole turtleneck episode
keeping the turtleneck on so be proud of
me please and also my I'm so my stomach
and my chest is so [ __ ] beated up
dude it's so beated up anyway we got to
go somebody's cell phone is [ __ ]
going off or something anyway that's it
all right you guys thanks so much for
listening this has been the turtleneck
episode you guys ripped and I really
appreciate you guys thank you so much
okay
oh also text me at eight one eight two
three nine seventy eighty seven
Thanks Oh new merch no not new merch but
restock is coming this next week so do
that this [ __ ] goes so fast come see me
in West Palm Beach West Palm Beach and
Brea California and I have finally
getting a date to my new special I have
it but I can announce it so let me know
guys you guys are the best thank you so
much to listen
[Music]